الارجنتين استقبال الابطال في بوني ستارز
في الساعات الاولى من فجر اليوم بعد وصول
الطائرات التي اقلت ليونيل ميسي ورفاقه
عقب الفوز بكاس العالم لكره القدم
هذه لقطات مباشره من بويسايرس وهذه
المشاهد مكرره من ليله
همم المباراه النهائيه بين الارجنتين
وفرنسا ونرى المنتخب الارجنتيني همم يخترق
الحشود علمتني حافله بس مكشوفه ويعني
يقومون بتحيه
للجماهير الذين كانوا بانتظار هذا الفوز
التاريخي
للارجنتين كانت مباريات مهمه جدا من اجمل
المباريات في همم المونديالات السابقه بين
فرنسا والارجنتين الفريقين لاعبه بطريقه
مميزه جدا لدرجه ان الحسن كان ضربات
الترجيحيه كانت فعلا مباريات مميزه هذا
المشهد همم يتكرر من ليلتين او ثلاثه
اعتقد يوم المونديال 18
هذه الساحه في بونس ايرس مقتدر بالحشود
وبعشاق كره القدم وتحديدا المنتخب
الارجنتيني
ليونيل ميسي كان نجم هذه المباريات وكان
هناك الكثير من الجدل على او حول ابقاء
رونالدو على هامش هذه
الجيم او اللعبه
ويعني الكثير من
تحليلات ستاتي في الايام المقبله ولكن
الفوز هو الفوز وطبعا كان حاضر الرئيس
الفرنسي اماره المباراه بشكل شخص
ليؤيد فريقه الفرنسي الذي لعب بشكل جيد
جدا ايضا
اذا حافيه تقل المنتخب الارجنتيني
تخترق الحصود في وسط بوليس ايرس هذه
اللقطات لميسي
بعتقد اذا كانت الصوره واضحه فعلا ميسي
وهو كان نجم هذا الفريق رغم انه الجميع
لاعبه بطريقه محترفه جدا
وكسبوا
كاس عن جداره
الاف الحشود متواجده في بونس ولكن نعيش
طبيعات الممتعال الذي كان مميز جدا يعني
حتى المغرب البلد همم ايضا فريق المغرب
يصل اليوم همم الى بلاد ايه وهناك
احتفالات كبيره لاستقبال ايه
بعدك ايضا دور تاريخي قام به المنتخب
المغربي في هذا المونديال
[موسيقى]
الفوز الجميل
دي المنتخب الارجنتيني
الانتصارات جميله دائما وهذا وهذا صوت
النصر من العاصمه
[موسيقى]